فرضته الولايات المتحده وبريطانيا عقوبات
على شبكات الكبتاجون في سوريا استهدفت
اشخاص مرتبطين اشخاصا مرتبطين بنظام رجال
اعمال واقارب للاسد لتورطهم في تجاره
الخزانه الامريكيه اعلنت النواطن اصدرت
عقوبات تشمل منتجين ومصدرين
تستهدف سته اشخاص بينهم اربعه من عائله
رئيس سوري والمقربين منهم اضافه الى
شركتين وذكرت الخزانه الامريكيه لسوريا
اصبحت تطلع بدور عالمي كبير في انتاج مخدر
الكبتاجون والذي يتم تهريب معظمه عبر
لبنان كما اشارت الى ان بعض محاربين
المخدرات اللبنانيين الذين لهم صلات مع
ميليشيات حزب الله
يطلعون ايضا بدور مهم لتسهيل تصدير هذا
المخدر هذا وشددت الخارجات الامريكيه على
نواشنطن ستواصل مع الحلفاء مواجهه تجاره
المخدرات في سوريا والمنطقه تحديدا
سوريا وتجاره الكبتاجون
سوريا تمثل مصدرا لامدادات العالم من
الكبتاجون
مسؤولون في النظام متورطون في تجاره
السلطات السوريه تقول انه لا توجد معامل
لتصنيع الكبتاجون في البلاد
استغلت الجار المخدرات والمهربون سوريا
كدوله لعبور المخدرات بحسب السلطات
السوريه تقارير واحصاءات تشير الى ان اكثر
من 400 مليون حبه كبتاجون تم ضبطها في
الشرق الاوسط عام 2021
المتحدث باسم المصالحه السوريه اهلا بكما
الى بانوراما فنبدا مع السيد بشار جرار
قصه الكابتاكو في سوريا معروفه منذ سنوات
طويله ولكن لماذا اثاره هذا الملف وبهذا
الحجم من واشنطن في هذا التوقيت
استاذ محمد شكرا لك والعربيه على الدعوه
الكريمه بمعيه الاخ الزميل عمر واقول ان
التوقيت سياسي بامتياز لا شك ان ما جرى من
جهود عربيه لتطبيع عربي سوري في الاونه
الاخيره وفوق ذاك الاتفاق الذي ضمنته
وتوسطت فيه الصين بين السعوديه وايران
يعتقد ان هذا الامر كان له رداد فعل يبدو
ان هذه اولها من جانب اداره الرئيس بايدن
فهناك رساله ينبغي توجيهها وقد اختار
الموضوع الاكثر اجماعا وهو الحرب على
السموم المسماه المخدرات المخدرات وتحديدا
اصبح قضيه تعني لان هذه حرب اخترقت الحدود
لعدد من الدول الحلفاء بواشنطن وارتبطت
بما في الارهاب وهي حرب لا تقل ضراوه عنها
وبالتالي التوقيت اختي ربي بعنايه واعتقد
انه فيه رساله وقد تلتقط من الاطراف
المعنيه على الاقل هكذا يتامل كثيرا طيب
سيد عمران هل واشنطن بالفعل جاده في
محاربه وهل يتخلى نظام الاسد عن هذه
المخدرات او على الاقل حلفاء النظام من
اجل استيعابهم في المنطقه بشكل اكبر خاصه
بان دول رئيسيه في المنطقه متضرره من
تجاره الكبته في سوريا
تحيه لك وللاخ والصديق الاستاذ بشار
الجراوي والساده المشاهدين يعني في
الحقيقه الروايه الامريكيه التي طرحت بان
عائدات وارباح المخدرات تعود لسوريا ب 57
مليار دولار يعني الغريب الذي لا يصدق بان
ميزانيه الدوله ميزانيه سوريا بجيشها
وتربيتها وزراعتها وكل وزاراتها هي خمسه
مليار دولار فقط ميزانيه سوريا بالعام كله
5 مليار فهل يعقل ان امريكا التي حاصرت
سوريا حاصرت الهواء وحاصرت الماء ومنعت
النفط ومنعت الوقود الوصول للشعب السوري
للتدفئه
ان تعجز عن منع المخدرات ثم يعني هذا
الرقم مبالغ به هذا الشيء الثاني هي في
الحقيقه استمرار امريكا في حرب ومحاصره
الشعب السوري يعني هي بموازات قيصر عندما
فشل قيصر بعد الزلزال بعد التطبيع العربي
المجتمع الدولي ودول كثيره الى سوريا
لتقديم الدعم والمساعدات للشعب السوري
ونهايه قانون قيصر كان من المناسب لامريكا
ان توجد شيئا غير قيصر لكي يدعم حصان
الشعب السوري ويقتل الشعب السوري بشكل
اكثر في الحقيقه هذه الروايه يعني انا
اعيش في سوريا
والجهاز مكافحه المخدرات في سوريا لا
يتوقف لان سوريا هي دوله ممر وليست مصنعا
يعني من يسمع الى الروايه الامريكي
الامريكيه يظن بان سوريا هي التي تصنع وهي
عندها مصانع وعندها معامل وعندها ارض جزء
فيها الافيون او الحشيش في افغانستان يعني
هذه الروايه في الحقيقه غير التصدير وغير
في سوريا من عدمها ليست قصتنا هذه الليله
ولكن هذا يدفعني الى سؤال السيد بشار جرار
يعني تقريبا 65 مليار دولار عائدات
الكيبتك يزيد باضعاف عن ميزانيه الدوله
السوريه هل هذا معقول واين تذهب تلك
الاموال بالفعل اذا كانت بهذا الحجم
وعزيزي
بدايه قد يكون من الاولى ان يتحدث فيه
الجانب الرسمي ولكن منطقيا بالفعل انا
تراودني بكثير من الشكوك حول التضخيم
التضخيم وهذه لعبه يعني معروف انه يتم
اعتمادها لغايات دعائيه يراد منها الضغط
السياسي ولكن لدينا مشكله وهذا ما اتمنى
ان يتفق عليه كل منصف ومجرد من اي دوافع
اخرى عندما يتعامل مع قضيه تمس وتهدد
الوجود البشري وتودد كيانات وطنيه ودول
هذا يستهدف الشباب لاقي الخطوره ابدا هذا
ارهاب
وهذه معركه يفترض ان تكون مشتركه واتمنى
واعتقد
ان كثيرين عبروا عن وجهات النظر هذه بان
من مسهلات ومحفزات التطبيع العربي السوري
الان حل هذه القضيه لانها قضيه حقيقيه
عندما تشكو بلادك الاردن والسعوديه وعدد
من دول الاقليم من افه المخدرات حتى
العراق العراق الاقرب الى ايران هناك صرخه
مدويه حتى في اوساط متحالفه مع الحكومه في
ايران والحكم في العراق بان هناك مشكله
مخدرات وصلت وتجاوزت 80% بمناطق تسيطر
عليها ميليشيات لها ما يواها ويحرفها على
الارض السوريه واللبنانيه في هذا الموضوع
وهذا عزيزي الله علاقه له على الاطلاق
بتجزيء او الحرب على على الارهاب لان هناك
من تحالفوا للاسف لمد الارهاب ومن كان
يحارب الارهاب ايضا في هذه الادوات بغايات
تحفيز المقاتلين وتوفير السيوله هذه مشكله
حقيقيه لا يمكن طمعها طيب مره اخرى سيد
عمر رحمون هل
موضوع
هو ما قد يؤدي او يعرقل التقارب العربي
سوري على الاقل وحسب وجهه واشنطن خلال
الفرض المزيد على او من العقوبات على دمشق
نعرب بينه في الفتره الاخيره كان هناك
تقارب عربي سوري لافت هذا التقارب قد يفيد
النظام نعم ولكنه قد يفيد بشكل مباشره
الشعب السوري لفك الحصار قانون قيصر
العقوبات على الكبتاجون هل ستعرقل هذا
التقارب
الشعب السوري عندما ايقظت امريكا بنهايه
مفعول قانون قصه بموضوع الزلزال وتهافت
الناس لمساعده الشعب السوري اخترعوا قانون
اما انا اقول لك الان نحن في سوريا بحاجه
المحروقات بحاجه اكل بحاجه طعام لا يوجد
عندنا
ما فيه حتى تجاره المخدرات طيب بشار بعيدا
عن المبالغه في الارقام المتعلقه بتجاره
في سوريا هل يستفيد النظام او على الاقل
حلفاء النظام من هذه التجاره وهل من
الممكن والنمو تجاره بهذا الحجم سواء من
خلال مصانع الكبتاجون او كون سوريا ممر
للكبتاجون مما يضر دول مجاوره مثل
السعوديه
والاردن الا يستفيد النظام بشكل او باخر
من هذه التجاره وهل سيتخلى عنها مستقبلا
هو ما نتمناه هو ما سمعناه من الزبير بن
دمشق ان تكون هذه مصلحه وطنيه السوريه
وسياسيه في الصميم لمن يحكم سوريا بان هذا
الامر اساء للعلاقات مع الدول العربيه
واساءلوا السوره سوريا امام العالم ولكن
الانصاف يفترن القول بان كل ساحه حرب كل
ساحه ارهاب تتعرض لنوع من الانفلات الامني
هذا الانفلات الامني هناك من يتطفل على
هذه الحاله ويوظفها لصالح الجرائم الجرائم
ليست فقط مخدرات الاتجار بالبشر هذه قضايا
عزيزيه لا يعيب اي نظام في الدنيا ان يقر
انها مشكله موجوده مشكله المخدرات مرتبطه
في افغانستان مرتبطه بايران مرتبطه بتركيا
هذه ساحات منتجه وتبحث عن اماكن تصدير
المشكله في
هذه اللعنه بانها ارتبطت ولا احد يستطيع
منصف ان ينكر بانها ارتبطت للاسف في اشخاص
تنظيمات ثم اما شئت في سوريا ولبنان
وانتهزوا فرصه الحرب والحصار واستغلوا ذلك
لتطوير اموال لم تعد متوفره بعد تجديد
العقوبات على ايران من مصلحه سوريا خاصه
في مرحله التقارب العربي التوجه هنا هذا
ليس سرا ان هناك اجتماعات تمت من وزراء
متخصصين في الامن والمخابرات وكان في
صداره ما تم طرحه هي قضيه المخدرات لانها
اصبحت قضيه امن قومي بعدد من الدول
العربيه وهي تصب في مصلحه سوريا ولكل من
يريد الخير لسوريا والانتهاء هذه الحاله
الغير طبيعيه التي استمرت اكثر من عقد
سيبدا عمر رحمون اخيرا هل ستتخلى سوريا او
حلفاء النظام عن هذه التجاره في مقابل
تقارب عربي اكبر مستقبلا
يا سيدي الكريم وانا داخل سوريا صدقني
اكثر جهاز في الدوله يعمل لا هو جهاز
مكافحه المخدرات واكثر جهاز يعاني من
التعب والعناء ليله نهار ولكن يبدو سيدنا
رحمون بان هذه الجهود غير مثمره حتى الان
المخدرات تشرح وتمرح في محاوله للوصول الى
حدود اقوى مثل حدود الاردنيه والسوريه
يا سيدي انت امام بلد مدمر انت امام بلد
مدمر صرح فيه الارهاب ومرح ودمره
والدوله السوريه بما يملك من ادوات
وتحارب هذا هذه التجاره وتحاول منعها
تحاول منعها لامرين لانها امر مضر والثاني
لانها تضر المصلحه السوريه العربيه ولكثير
من الاسباب سوريا تحاربها لكن سوريا
بامكانياتها تعمل كل ما بوسعها لمنع هذه
التجاره
نامل ان تستطيع ان تمنع هذه التجاره في
قادم الايام من واشنطن والشر جرار الكتب
المحلل السياسي من دمشق عمر رحمون المتحدث
باسم المصالحه السوريه شكرا جزيلا لكم